[Music]
oh
no hello my name is grace helbig if you
did not know now you know your life is
different
now we're in the kitchen we're doing
another cooking video and this one i'm
very excited about because it's
something i've never made before
and it's very comforting who doesn't
want something mysterious
and comforting i'm getting a call from
puerto rico right now that's
mysterious not comforting we just pushed
the phone a little further away that
usually does it welcome to another hello
fresh cooking video if you don't know
what hellofresh is
i'm going to tell you because i have
some talking points with hellofresh you
can get mouth-watering
why i can't remember hellofresh is
america's number one meal kit they give
you
mouth-watering seasonal recipes with
pre-measured ingredients that get
delivered right to your door
you want to leave it's fun easy and
affordable that would be
my tagline if i was a sex worker support
sex workers
we're going to stop talking about the
worldly matters we're talking about
mouth matters oh the talking point is no
matter what's going on in the world
everybody's got to eat true they have
low calorie recipes they have family
friendly recipes
they have vegetarian recipes
not this one you can get one of their
recipes onto the table in about 30
minutes 20 minutes if you try their
quick and easy recipes and because all
of their meals come with pre-measured
ingredients there is less
less waste and hellofresh is super
flexible you can change your delivery
dates you can change the type of meals
that you want delivered you can skip a
week if you need to you can feel good
about using hellofresh in 2019
hellofresh donated 2.5
million meals to charities and they're
looking to do more
this year this is a win-win-win all the
way around let's get into what we're
making today
you'll never guess go ahead i'm gonna
give you a second to guess try and guess
horrible awful terrible guesses i'm sure
you're probably good at something else
but it wasn't
guessing what we're doing today that's
for sure today we are making
pub style shepherd's pie because i don't
give a [ __ ]
yes it was over 100 degrees here in los
angeles
neri two days ago what does nary mean
non-standard form of not that works
nothing makes sense
right now so i'm gonna make whatever i
want and i don't care if it's seasonally
inappropriate i've never made something
like this before so i want to challenge
myself
and i want to get a warm
gastrointestinal hug at the end of it so
first off and calm down and watch this
video and enjoy yourself
damn it everything comes in a
mysteriously wonderful brown paper bag
no eggs right hello
you all look great get ready to party i
want you guys to form a dense
thick aggressively sloppy situation that
goes
in me and then chooses its own adventure
once it's inside
wash and dry all produce
the magic of storytelling it's all
washed and dried diced potatoes
into half inch pieces little starchy
spheres of ah potatoes just feel
like that kind of ambitionless best
friend
oh and i already washed my hands before
this
yesterday i ate matzo ball soup and
played video games
like i was 67 and 17 all at the same
time
oh so cool potatoes have been chopped
into our little pieces
now i'm not gonna do it
we're just gonna move on and consider
you a carrot peel and have the carrot
plus a carrot
there's nothing phallic about you don't
give in to innuendos pull out don't
forget you can use your
bag that it came in as a trash bag as
you go there ain't a bobbitt in the
kitchen over here bam
carrot's been cut finally dice our
celery
i need a bigger knife perfect if you
guys don't know this by now i have a
real affinity to food
that's in what i affectionately refer to
as a slop trough
this seems like it's going to really
deliver we need to half
peel and finally chop our onions ooh
that smells like an
onion it goes in our little garbage bag
i love an accessory trash on trash wow
this
giant knife feels great in my hands
that's not something
that someone who's been cooped up in
their house for six months should say
confidently out loud
now on to the time we need to strip the
leaves off the stems with your consent
thank you and we chop up the time
beautiful
oh my eyes are experiencing moisture i
don't even want to
let my eyes get kind of moist because i
feel like i'm very sensitive as
i'm sure most of you are in these weird
times so if my body
even gets the false sense of crying it's
gonna like double down and go oh we're
really in this here we go
floodgate tears okay on to step two here
we go we're making progress
now what we can say about some other
things going on in the world but we got
this we need to place our potatoes in a
medium pot with enough salted water to
cover by two
inches and we're gonna boil and cook for
15 to 20 minutes
potatoes are on when the potatoes are
done we're gonna mash them
make our mashed potatoes but we're gonna
let them boil for a bit we're gonna let
them get all
hot and bothered and when they're at
their most vulnerable state we're gonna
smash them yep while the potatoes cook
we're moving on to step
three we're gonna work on our filling
how excited how excited i'm already
speaking
in past tense ah heat a drizzle of oil
in a medium
oven-proof pan add the carrot season
with salt and pepper
and cook for two to three minutes here's
my favorite pan it is dirty i've really
considered not cleaning it
and just using it but i'm better than
that
question mark i also feel like this is a
really good recipe because it seems like
kind of foolproof
it's all just getting warmed and smashed
together it's like pre-chewed baby food
for adults which i'm not better than
carrots cook for two to three minutes
that gives us enough time
to catch up with each other in a real
way i'm just gonna cook some carrots
and um keep my emotional distance
this is the kind of shirt where it's
perfectly acceptable for you to stare
directly at my tits
squint hard see what you see take it all
in we're gonna add
celery add our onion a little bit more
oil
some salt and pepper and then we're
gonna let that cook for five to seven
minutes
and because i have the option to fill
time
with conversation and attempt to connect
to you emotionally
in a relatable and poignant way i'm not
okay or stuffing stuffing filling yeah
has cooked for about five minutes so now
we're gonna add
our thyme and our garlic powder and cook
for another 30 seconds now we're on to
step four we're gonna add our beef
my apologies as always to those of you
that are vegetarian
i respect you deeply look away
there's gotta be a better way to have
done this why why
all right that could have been done way
better says everyone about the last six
months
and now we cook the base so far i can
describe this meal
the way my gynecologist has never
described
my area smells great nothing like making
a big old tub of shepherd's pie at 4
30 p.m on a tuesday you know when those
shepherds aren't in those
fields doing sheep [ __ ] they're in the
kitchen
making dreams come true this pandemic
has allowed me to start thinking about
the questions that really matter
are shepherds stoners we add our tomato
paste
and flour and we cook stirring until
thoroughly combined for one minute let's
put these in that
and see what happens we're gonna make it
thick and dry you said it
now we're going to gradually pour one
half cup of water into the pan with the
beef mixture
and stir in the stock concentrate cook
until mixture is very thick
one to two minutes it does look like a
cat has thrown up
oh right our potatoes okay i turned the
heat off because now we have to make our
mashed potatoes remember we forgot about
those guys all right okay we gotta get
more time for our potatoes
okay i got everything under control and
listen to me because i know what i do
i know exactly what i'm doing so
everyone shh
you already had a chance to try and
guess what meal we were cooking
it up so
butter we need butter everything hot
do the potatoes we add our sour cream we
add two tablespoons of butter
and a teaspoon of thyme and we mash them
up i don't have a masher
so i'm just gonna put a fork in there
and just around a bit these potatoes
probably could have cooked for longer
this is
difficult for you to watch what i'm
doing here hard for me to be a part of
and
see there's got to be a better way to do
this what if i just started mashing them
up with my bare hands
this this you're cool i love my dog back
there
wear a cookie mask i'm out okay so now
we are going to put the mashed potatoes
on
top of our beef mixture and we're gonna
sprinkle with some cheddar cheese
and we're gonna put it in the oven on
broil for three to four minutes
this is a sobriety compromised person's
dream
my god and that goes for three to four
minutes
and then we find ourselves transported
to the promised land
oh let's clean up i don't want i when
this comes out of the oven i want to be
presentable i'm so nervous
i feel like i'm getting ready for a date
oh my god you just serve it directly
from the pan
oh this is a great meal you don't have
to do
anything other than just let it take you
over oh my god
the fact that i'm wearing sweatpants i
feel like a debutant
my date's almost here everyone shut the
[ __ ] up and be cool oh my gosh i think
it's done
oh my god look at this thing hi
i'm grace how big
you do not know now you know
[Music]
okay like this is how she looks on her
dating profile and you're like wow
what a mess can't take her home to mom
but let's
just see maybe it's a weird photo and
then this is how she shows up and you're
like holy [ __ ] she
is actually a mess and this is great i
don't want to take her home to mom my
mother and i have a terrible
relationship oh my god i'm so excited
about this
this turned out exactly as i hope you
guys
know and if you don't know get ready if
you are interested all in hello fresh
which i
obviously highly recommend if you're
interested you can use my code global80
to get 80
off including free shipping on your
first box with purchase go to
hellofresh.com to redeem
and get more details okay without
further ado i'm gonna
put you in my mouth and we're both gonna
have a great time and i forgive you
for the tragedies that i'm gonna
encounter in the future because of you
[Music]
that's so good oh that's so good and you
can eat it out of the pan like this
you can eat it over the sink oh you can
just really
let yourself go this thing shows up on
the first date like you're already six
months into a relationship i'm
barely hanging on oh you nasty in a good
way well there you go guys i hope you
enjoyed this video thanks for watching
if you did give it a thumbs up leave a
comment down below if you've made any
hello fresh meals or any meals for that
matter i'm so happy subscribe to this
youtube channel
make videos yeah other than that
i don't know we didn't start the fire
it was lame people who think they're
interesting by having
pyrotechnics reveal the gender of their
unborn
child at an unnecessary event during a
global pandemic that started a fire
i like this recipe because you only need
a little bit of time
you don't need a huge celery
and
onion